Mother Wolf saw a movement among the trees.
"Something is coming," she said.
Father Wolf got ready to jump at whatever came out of the trees.
But to his surprise, it was not an animal.
It was a man's cub.
A little brown baby.
At this moment, Shere Khan came to the mouth of the cave.
"I am looking for a man's cub," Shere Khan said.
"His parents were afraid of me and they ran off."
"Now, I can eat their child."
Father Wolf said, "The man cub is ours."
Shere Khan roared, "You have no right to keep the child."
Then, Mother Wolf shouted at the tiger, "Go away!"
"The child stays with us and will run with our family."
Shere Khan roared, "The wolf pack will decide, not you",...
..."if a man's cub can run with the pack."
Father Wolf said, "Shere Khan is right, Mother."
"The pack will decide if he may run with us."
"We will take Mowgli, for this is what I shall call him",...
..."to the pack at the next full moon," Mother Wolf said.
Time passed, and Mother, and Father Wolf took Mowgli to where Akela, the great, gray wolf who led the pack...
...was lying outside his cave.